c'est mon choix et vous avez pas à juger
du tout c'est ce que je dirais à ma
fille quoi mais non mais je suis pas
votre film
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fait là-dedans c'est qu'on lui a pas
demandé son avis puisque il a perdu la
boule je préfère avoir une vidéo faite
par sa famille plein d'amour qui soit
shooté par des papa
qui juste après avoir posté cette vidéo
parce que c'est pas sa femme de Mimi
Morin son ex-femme sa vraie femme qui
est mal à l'heure actuelle avec il a eu
deux enfants a posté après une vidéo sur
Instagram en disant qu'elle avait mis
cette vidéo au vu de tout le soutien
qu'elle avait reçu d'énormément fans
elle trouvait ça normal de donner des
nouvelles entre guillemets et pour aussi
prévenir et montrer sur cette planète
pas ton énervement par rapport à ça en
vrai merci
[Rires]
à la marge
le second
il va pour souffler et il bascule et il
bascule et je suis désolé
je ne critique pas la famille mais en
revanche je trouve que effectivement ça
n'aide personne
des fans qui l'aiment avant tout pour
son franc-parler j'aime pas les jaloux
gros bisous comment ça va en vrai ça va
parce que je vais relativiser on arrive
bien se sortir on soutient beaucoup avec
ma maman mon frère mon frère ma sœur
c'est vrai que du coup nous bah on avait
Laurent avait un petit peu critique on
va voir ce qu'il a dit il se trouve que
on ne sait réagir moi en tant que mec
qui a bossé avec Jean-Pierre panneau à
une vidéo que tu as fait il y a un nom
on diffuse cette vidéo ici et je te vois
en larmes en train de dire je sais que
tu as 18 19 ans et en train de dire j'en
peux plus c'est trop dur c'est trop dur
ce que je veux dire c'est que quand on
me demande ce que j'en pense qu'est-ce
que tu veux que je dise d'autre à part
ce que je conseillerais à loup c'est de
prendre son téléphone de ouvrir son Tik
Tok et de le fermer pendant quelques
mois si ça lui fait tant de mal vous
avez dit à ce moment là et ce jour-là où
vraiment j'étais vraiment plus bas que
terre ok si je faisais des vidéos je
pleurais c'est parce que tout le monde
me demandait comment j'allais et comment
je faisais pour sourire donc je me
disais si une critique quand je souris
autant montrer quand je pleure parce que
autant montrer toute ma personnalité
c'est mon choix et vous avez pas à le
juger du tout ce que j'ai pas fait
techniquement faire des études buzz je
fais je suis en étude architecture
d'intérieur
je trouve ça débile de faire ça enfin
pardon c'est pas vous cadez
elle protège sa famille
de quel roi permettait d'aventure de ma
fille qui vit douloureusement la perte
de son papa soit disant proche de mon
mari défunt renseigne-toi à votre
vouloir faire du buzz à la télé si vous
vous dites que vous étiez un alimentaire
que vous le connaissiez tout ça tout ça
dans ce cas-là est-ce que pourquoi
est-ce que ce jour-là moi j'ai perdu mon
père de semaine avant dans peut-être
deux mois avant je sais plus vous êtes
là et vous dites n'importe quoi sur moi
vous me connaissez pas et vous me taquez
alors vous êtes censé être son ami parce
que je ne dis pas n'importe quoi
c'est extrêmement extrêmement personnel
tu avais quoi ce 15 16 ans quand tu as
vu ton papa
est-ce que est-ce que tu es allé sur sa
tombe depuis oui bah oui et tu vas
régulièrement d'accord très bien c'était
une question parce que moi j'y arrive
pas mais si jamais tu as besoin que je
t'accompagne
et merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis passé complètement à côté du
fait que c'est une chanson contre la
violence faite aux femmes bah oui parce
qu'en fait à l'époque à l'époque donc
j'étais avec un homme et il me foutait
sur la gueule mais moi en tant que mais
tu sais quand moi quand tu me tapes je
te tape si tu veux et vous portez pas
plainte
là on a tendance chez lui on va voilà
quoi c'est nettement j'ai fait ça hein
pour leur frapper bien sûr c'est
incroyable mais on réglé ça entre nous
quoi il y avait pas de
oui sur Camping Paradis plus les années
passées moi on m'écrivait le texte je
trouvais pas de place et j'étais
l'actrice la moins payée à ce que moi
c'est vrai que j'étais actrice la moins
payée bon alors
je pense que c'est parce que j'avais un
mauvais agent qui avait mal négocié
c'est un truc qui était interne moi j'en
parle parce que j'ai une grande gueule
et je ferai des fois mieux de la fermer
mais j'en ai parlé comme ça et ça a été
à coller comme si c'était parce que
j'étais noir que j'étais moi alors moi
j'ai pas dit que c'était parce que
j'étais noir mais il se trouve que c'est
quand même parallélisme vous dites la
chanson MMA qui a été reprise pour trop
dedans vous vous l'avez dit donc c'est
très bien bravo vous rapporte 60 000 €
par mois alors ça aussi je reviens
là-dessus parce que contexte 80000 il me
pose la question il me fait
peur
et moi je joue le jeu je dis 60000 parce
que tu es je veux pas qu'il descend trop
bas quand même
mais si tu veux un jour je t'emmène mes
fiches d'impôts mais c'est tellement pas
ça c'est tellement pas et en plus
aujourd'hui on voit bien que ben ils
prennent juste et même ah bon ben voilà
là
et il dit que je comprends que les
chaînes mais dégagées puisque avec deux
Chavannes j'étais certainement l'une des
personnes les plus ingérables on
acquables souvent les animateurs en
disant c'est des gros cons ils ont pris
la grosse tête et tout mais c'est
souvent aussi à cause des chaînes parce
que quand on a une émission qui marche à
l'animateur on le met au sommet on lui
dit tu es formidable tu es une princesse
tout réussit machin on les met au sommet
du coup on prend le molo et une fois que
l'émission ne marche plus santé non mais
oui non mais c'est vrai on nous met
toujours au sommet les animateurs par
les chaînes quand ça fonctionne bien
donc nous on prend le melon et une fois
que ça fonctionne moins bien et ben on
nous fout dehors alors Laurent il a un
double visage Vincent c'est quelqu'un
qui effectivement tout ce qui dit lui
est vrai moi j'ai vécu en tant que
producteur on a failli faire un pilote
ensemble où il m'a maltraité ou il n'a
pas été très sympa donc des hélicoptères
pour venir ils étaient pas d'accord avec
l'horaire sur lequel TF1 voulait le
mettre ouais c'est un peu cause c'est
compliqué mais mais c'est Benjamin
Castaldi qui a fait le truc au final
mais à la fois c'est un mec qui a un
énorme cœur et qui a par exemple peu de
gens savent toujours fait travailler
dans ces équipes techniques des gens qui
sortaient de tôle et il était en
réinsertion donc voilà un type qui était
à double visage très populaire quand il
est venu assez vite et que Cyril lui a
filé les émissions de qui qui cartonnait
qui a fait un million strike ça fait un
million Cyril lui a offert un pont d'or
il y a eu un million 11 millions pardon
11 émissions de signer il va sur Europe
1 et le premier truc qui dit c'est dès
que TF1 m'appelle j'y vais bien sûr ça
énervé Cyril la chaîne aussi justement
perso j'ai pas trouvé que c'était un
type très bien je pense que quand on est
animateur évidemment on devient célèbre
et puis quand on dirige ton émission on
la produit donc on est en son propre
artistique et quand il y a quelqu'un de
la chaîne la diffusion qui vient vous
raconter la messe alors que cette
personne n'a jamais fait de télé je
pense c'est ça qui a énervé non mais
c'est ça qui a énervé il y a une
quinzaine d'années
parce que petit à il répond toujours
cash et il assume ce qu'il a dit sans
revenir en arrière coûte et plus et en
plus pardon il s'est effectivement il
peut être une tête de con mais plus plus
les gens sont plus en plus peut-être de
quoi avec eux ils menacent plus la base
c'est pas faux
[Musique]
Mathieu comment veux-tu qu'elle est le
même visage à 20 ans qu'elle a 70 au
bout d'un moment elle a du mal à
vieillir comme toutes ses actrices elle
essaie de se rattraper au branches moi
j'en veux pas je sais pas où on sera
nous mais oui mais notre abîme pas mais
Ryan à la République normalement madame
magrets c'est un poisson lune
chirurgien bonjour massacrer moi elle
avait des en tête d'être plus belle et
malheureusement ça a raté là je vais
vous donner ils sont prévenus de ce des
dégâts que ça fait bizarre les gens ils
y retournent ils veulent travailler il y
a des jeunes qui vont de plus en plus
tôt maintenant tu vas te faire les
cheveux
il est pas obligé il est pas obligé je
l'ai pas encore fait tu as quel âge là
j'ai 51 [__] mais ça incroyable tu es
magnifique et on voit que tu es sportif
un an deux ans d'écart je t'emmerde mais
de quoi